Consciousness is defined as the state of being
awake and aware of one's surroundings, it’s
the mind’s understanding that it exists.
And it is one of the most elusive phenomena
in all of human understanding.
To try and shed light on this mystery, scientists
are searching for a biological explanation
they call the neural correlates of consciousness.
Which means, the parts of your brain that
supposedly generate self-awareness.
Aaaaand …. they might have found a key component!
Researchers at the Allen Institute for Brain
Science uncovered three giant neurons, one
of which is projected across the cortex of
a mouse brain like a “crown of thorns!”
They’ve traced these special neurons to
what’s believed to be one of the most densely
connected parts of the brain.. called the
claustrum.
Scientists have hypothesized that the claustrum
could be coordinating inputs and outputs to
create conscious experiences … so seeing
these three giant neurons extend from the
claustrum was a big deal.
The claustrum is a tiny sheet of neurons just
below the cortex, and there’s one on each
hemisphere of the brain.
Scientists suspect the claustrum is a highly
integrated region, and could have more anatomical
connections than any other part of our brain.
It’s potentially connected to many cortical
areas that are crucial for perception, like
vision, movement and hearing.
When studying the region, famous neuroscientist
Francis Crick, (yes, one of the guys that
discovered the structure of DNA) proposed
that subjective consciousness is possible
thanks to the claustrum, which could be acting
like some kind of "conductor" in the mind.
For instance, if your brain were an orchestra,
he suspected the claustrum is responsible
for keeping the myriad pieces and instruments
playing together…
Crick explained this orchestration concept
best when he described the experience of picking
a rose.
You can hold the rose in your hands, smell
its fragrance, see its red petals … and
your mind processes this as a unified, subjective
experience.
The thing is, the claustrum conductor is just
a hypothesis.
But there was one recent study that gave brain
scientists pause.
In 2014, a study was published detailing a
woman with epileptic seizures who underwent
deep brain stimulation.
When electrodes near her left claustrum were
stimulated, she immediately stopped what she
was doing and stared blankly into space, she
didn’t even respond to calls or gestures.
When they turned off the treatment, she regained
consciousness and didn’t even remember what
happened!
It was almost like they discovered an on-and
off switch deep inside her brain! (wtf!!!!)
The claustrum could be the key to figuring
this all out, but we don’t know for sure
… consciousness is still the ultimate enigma.
Looking for connections in the brain also
isn't enough to explain whether consciousness
is actually present.
It’s more complicated that that.
Some of the brightest minds in physics think
that consciousness is something the brain
can’t ever solve, but we’ll leave that
for the philosophers and scientists to fight
over.
So, what do you think?
Let us know in the comments.
We can’t do DNews episodes without our sponsors.
Thanks to Graze for sponsoring this episode.
Graze makes snacking exciting by combining
wholesome ingredients with flavors we all
love, to create over 100 nutritionist-approved
snacks.
Go to graze.com and enter promo code SEEKER
to get a free, sampler box delivered to your
home or work.
Now there’s a lot we still need to learn
about the brain but one of my burning questions
is...could we survive with only half of one?
Julian has more on this here.
Thanks for watching Seeker, don’t forget
to like and subscribe for more new videos.